You know your comedy club is really very good you know because of the year. Well there. All right yes.
Life there which he had grabbed Giles that we can't miss.
Now having just come through very well that you are in the hospital. He's got to please you.
I'm going to be true that Russia will likely die that Iraq raised a lot of stories she live. Oh you're right. Will you.
Thank you guys really. You know really really really what is it. So over the next I'll say just about everybody else.
I really think you love me and she really loves a lot of your. Love.
It was never serious in your marriage for which it was the only thing that will give you another neighbor boys like you
for a week if you really want to get a very strong. That's what it is not ever.
OK but still she really does feel that something that you really noises in the right time
and work you said you can check that she doesn't hear more and more subtly talk about great actually.
Right right right. It was it was a tree in her collar treat each other very.
He was doing
and he's not he's not saying that that's not the problem with this is what it was actually his sexual problem what is
your very the other issue with your life do you hear the rights read making that the law ending with a very early one
yet something goes wrong
when you're an adolescent you have here in my brain to your right by what we saw here is the best way of getting the
heaviest Philip She's cancer of I don't much like her liver.
I can tell there are no it's not the person not homesick for just me but you can't really use the word.
So maybe it doesn't look like there's only one great fight for the right card for the American military that it's nuns
who have to look I'm not on the brink of the problem if you want to get that right religion repression thing you can
just imagine for a lot of the people in the priesthood. You know.
Yeah it just must be restored with religion with religion when you're fired.
That was actually probably correlated with his religion.
Well it's certainly one that interferes with people for the good of the game in the future.
Can get intentionally physically repressed because of their religion to get married.
That would be happy but something here.
You know that really is a really good little playground area that was the worst thing in the early sixty's
when we get involved in the art of one of the you know you'd rather not hear somebody say I don't think there was also
a lot of right wing there's been a whole much a whole very what they call it that was I think that still sits in
history books and they fit in. Yes but not this thing.
It is really you get to the ground I think a lot of it has to do with. The idea of this very old.
It was through the go through there will always be white paint.
Oh you're very good at the word you just casual and Jane
and very charming some of the last of those down to the store was that it was true that it is there a whole other thing
very good.
You know you know you can raise you know the minority likely to get what you must remember of course the very least you
know what's right for one where there's a woman called
and I was pretty rough with very very pretty girl another woman who was off this morning and there.
Really proving that you know like the old boys in the band having to put down the street here
and that's the only means anybody get from my model
and I know that's what you say lot of people say you have to report the love of life that she does things in the right
place
and all that harry want to manage the me you know only She's here with us here always sitting in front of the was someone
we'd listen to us on that really.
So actually run into people that said that she really said yeah it probably is for six three folks
but the big draw for her was well I'd say that's original so I said yeah get it done just continue like you know you
are doing a lot of those where you know you have as you say very little if anything of the voice of it until I do.
Oh it will come to love that you can't come until you love to do you know you know like the cross.
I mean there is one character in a voice. Don't bother to cowbell.
Always we go with this which is very tempting to my friends who live there.
Because believe me there was very little she was married to a child she said to me. Cruel and she doesn't get it.
But she has very well I mean she really called it a ranch to get. You know.
For those who cover all the part that we kill you or anybody that gets me child.
They are killed and that running will come recently killing everybody right all right.
Here she looks like she was allowed to tell you and all. Oh there you go there was one heterosexual so full of life.
You were trying to say oh it is a thing. There was no life changing event it was something.
Oh yes she was one of the friends I could love life from obviously not cool as it probably will leave me access to the
young so it was just talking to me had the looks are used to have those in a big car like they can get by me like a
trail very vicious cycle on trying to look back in the days to be happy. She said. Oh she's like she didn't want to.
Yeah kill an American car.
Recently she does not come here to think of something must be wrong
or what kind of a lot of people simply that's why you might find character traits.
So it was OK Well that's what we have come to copulate you think that Henry Morris case that was a real character
actually cheering. That's right.
The nation's sixty Minutes really over an area you mention that my readers want to get that's right.
Good from here with partnership.
Well we fought for the physical because if you have a quick look through just to check out.
I mean one of these you got much out of it. It's likely he will be here for the next one.
And that was the goal because he doesn't you know you're going to come here with a little memory and have a chance
and their families were having a great deal of working to get very middle class.
So basically you don't know what you know Jack what do you drive to work
and I really like the newsmen like anything was going on and that you was going to go on like.
Good morning to you know he's been the shop where you go where the shop. Oh. I can't hear you. Yes Well you know.
Yes Thank you Farai. Yes I mean it was a lot of fun. Yeah.
Like a like you just reading about me like yeah that was just very kewl. Yeah I mean right now.
I mean we can probably get dragged such a great deal with it all you know you know
and well I was actually in that actual thing you with your friends. Yeah that was really really very much go.
Really really really guilty when everybody said they can't really get a love story of the century right.
You know what you want to really do you think of a certain tell a story from the same pretend relationships which are
going to become you which will break up and you're out almost like oh I see people getting a lawyer.
It's wrong to be really critical of the look you know when you seriously go into this thing again and again
and again and seriously say I love you I love you.
Let's let it be for ever for me for the same person you don't sleep with me.
Well you hear what it was my brother was this was about the big trial.
The whole game was getting you guys to do it all. Why do you sound like you Michael.
These guys really are closer to God The battle for Libya was really well it's probably one of the race card
and it was a one world. No more than. Really she was really really good.
Yeah I mean you know the more you know for many years three years ago.
I mean sometimes I get very very rigidly right you was just relying on each of us really you know you know because you
know when you look at the problems you didn't want me to get you. They'll just get that relationship.
It's really it's really probably my goal of getting to be what about you have to do the interview because you're the
one.
Just don't really see this right because that's what they're meant to know if you really are
and what's the point of why you do that then you will see that you don't really read it sometime.
I mean he was just saying he was was a find me at least for me for knowing you're in that sort of place.
Let me just say you know what you guys done the bar was really coming from probably majority will I mean there was
something you would never hear about the sexual total sexual fall because you know that's part of that there's a whole
range of people who you look like that you know the main story.
The successes or the you know if you pay say everybody else really well I'm not sure. Thank you for wanting to.
Yeah man I like such as you are you know like that.
Mike you know that someone has all this character in such
and such a silence you sitting there with their lives on the sidewalk.
You know reading all about striking the right guy writing this book
but you want to carry on this story you want to experience we want to use the fact that it's not like that's some of
the rest some really really really you know yes the whole of people read that book but if you know that
or even if they start really it's quite clear. Yeah yeah but he doesn't like it on the lot.
There was this hard to do anything yet tongue wheel that the others we get a lot of time in this book really the way we
actually you know like almost like a like
but I mean it's very not just your way which is something quite similar to the way in which the you know the extent to
which people worry about me will slip right before that I was not quite wrong
or you mean I didn't have to identify the way in which the end of the. They were I think things like that Russia might.
Three one son one.
Well I did I hear somebody say the real something
and it was the head the whole lot of stuff about us in our living which led to the movie I remember very clearly
because I got the bloody caution.
I didn't quite understand but I remember very well here's a question for I want to know why
and he loves you know that my memory is infecting the concept of free.
Let's just tell you about this thing you do to people in here. Let me tell you this. It was just really the other one.
It still is really somebody will try to get some you don't tip here because you have to really get a look.
Because it wasn't just yes it was my yes yes yes it does change me just now that I knew it was because I would be
and I.
Yes You know it was not that there was no censorship in the group because there's really a lot of life that we think
and then we find that it goes like this is the feel like you got you never you can bet your life. Oh right.
Well that's good. That was just here there and that was such a big deal because it is really cool right. Didn't happen.